Richard IATA you had a kind of weird
experience where in the IT Crowd you
thought you were playing a character
well I did a lot of research and for
that part where I play a geek I went
online and that was it
also Graham who wrote it he said I'm you
know I've written the parties for the
nerdiest person in the world I thought
of you that was that really yeah there
are no voices I think well it would have
been your own voice yeah I said do you
want me to do a voice to be the nerdiest
person he went no no just yours
but boss boss is one of those characters
that does delight people and even this
Halloween
so people were dressing up as Moss from
the IT Crowd and that you bother you
must have seen this picture there was a
little girl do you know this well look
it's the cheap costume it's a check
shirt oh don't - her dream well not this
is a little girl in America and she's a
big fan for Halloween she went as Moss
[Applause]
that's the emotional range is too large
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you